a wrangle doesn't have much of a
backstory it's a vaguely Soviet
post-apocalyptic dystopian abandoned
hellhole full of guns and homes to Lutz
and you and 99 strangers are jumping off
of a burning plane right into it
your parachute will ensure the fall
doesn't kill you but once you're down
there it's you against the island
[Music]
99 strangers are on the hunt for you and
each other every single one of them
wants to be the last one standing every
single one of them wants to win they
loot homes as soon as they land hunting
for weapons and armor scrounging the map
to find anything that could be of use
looking down your sights as you open the
door and a guy with a shotgun blasts you
in the face people have always wanted a
battle royale video game but it never
happened first came the original team
deathmatch island battle royale the
Japanese book and movie told the story
of 42 students dropped on a deserted
island and forced to kill each other
until only one was left got people
asking what they would do if they were
in that situation but the movie was not
released in the West for years leaving
it an obscure cult classic then years
later Hunger Games came around and it
reacted the fire people wanted battle
royale games but no one was making them
but one person wanted it more than
anybody else
Brenden player unknown green Brendon
green was not a game designer he was an
Irish photographer and web designer who
followed the love of his life to Brazil
two years later he was divorced and
looking to get his life back on track he
made it back home to Ireland and while
living on welfare Greene discovered the
games ARMA and dayz for those who don't
know ARMA is a hyper-realistic military
shooter known for the scale of its
combat its attention to detail and
graphic fidelity also known for being
the foundation for an incredible number
of mods many of which were spun off of
into their own games dayz is one of the
best-known armed
which use the hyper-realistic combat
mechanics to simulate a zombie
apocalypse so yeah I started off making
a mod basically back in ARMA 2 because I
want to make a game on one little play
I saw games like the survivor games
which were events for streamers I wanted
to play that myself so I decided to see
if I could actually make one and ARMA 2
but I was born the Battle Royale mod for
ARMA 2 was a departure from the tightly
directed experiences offered by Triple A
games like Assassin's Creed Green was
not interested in those types of games
he wanted something looser something
grittier it's something that gave you
the freedom to show what you would do in
a battle to the death as dayz broke free
of ARMA and became a standalone game
other developers took notice of how
popular green's mods were in the niche
arma community Sony Online Entertainment
now known as daybreak hired Greene as a
consultant on their own
dayz style zombie survival game that
mode eventually became h1z1 king of the
kill but by February 2016 Green had
moved on he was headed to Korea where he
got an interesting offer
Chang Han Kim a Korean game designer
working for blue Hall wanted to make a
battle royale game he was inspired by
Daisy but when he researched the battle
royale format more and more he kept
coming across green and less than 1
month later he was blue holes creative
director development moved fast Green
and Kim's team had the autonomy to
create the game that they wanted and
they wanted it to be playable within one
year
the game started its development in
early 2016
and the plan was to follow an early
access schedule Green and Kim wanted to
get the game in customers hands fast for
a low cost and keep improving it over
time but the foundation needed to be
laid down before anything else the team
made a small game one map one mode a
handful of weapons were added after the
launch but from the day it was released
on early access in March 2017 to today
battlegrounds has been the same game
however when it first came out there
wasn't quite anything like it
sure greens mods were still out there
but mods are never quite as popular as
standalone games battlegrounds was a
breath of fresh air amidst the high
budget lavishly produced shooters on the
market it was messy it was tense
[Music]
[Music]
and it was complicated but most
importantly it was fun the island is the
most important part to while green has
said that his team is working on more
maps a wrangle will always be the most
iconic thing about battlegrounds it's
the game's main character with familiar
landmarks wide open spaces and bizarre
unique topography it's not realistic
swamps farmland mountains and towns all
mingle together to make a backdrop that
has much of a hand in the action as the
players do and the players came to
battlegrounds fast for only $20 they got
to live the fantasy of surviving the
apocalypse the game's playerbase grew
every week 10 million rounds of
battlegrounds were played in the game's
first four months and it made 11 million
dollars in three days by April it had
sold a million copies one month later it
was at 2 million the next month it hit 4
million in August battlegrounds became
the most played game on Steam in terms
of concurrent players by September it
had beaten dota 2's record of 1.2 9
million concurrent players by October it
had hit 2 million players on Steam and
became the most popular game in South
Korean PC bombs beating longtime king
legends when the game cracked 2 million
copies sold blue will held a charity
Invitational tournaments three months
later ESL held the first major
battlegrounds tournament cementing a
possible eSports future for the game
Green told games industry dot biz that
he has always envisioned his mods to be
a spectator sport someday and his baby
was finally taking its first steps
people still ask if battlegrounds can be
an eSport it has the audience and the
player base the only problem is the
logistics gathering 100 people for a LAN
tournament is not the easiest thing in
the world which might limit it to events
like ESL ones and dream hacks what
eSports is not the only place
battlegrounds is growing the game is
selling more and more copies by the day
and even bigger companies are taking
notice Tencent made a deal to publish
the game in China Facebook cut a
streaming deal with blue Hall Epic Games
who assisted in modifying the Unreal
Engine 4 battlegrounds made a
battlegrounds inspired play mode for
their game fortnight in Microsoft touted
a timed console exclusive version of
battlegrounds for Xbox one at e3 2017 we
can't wait to bring player unknowns
battlegrounds exclusively to Xbox one
later this year with an update for Xbox
one X enhancements shipping with the
final version battlegrounds future is
bright there's no sign that the game
will stop growing anytime soon and with
imitators starting to crop up that just
gives battlegrounds more chances to
innovate and be better than the
competition
battlegrounds is the beginning of a new
video
genre and no one saw it coming thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button
[Music]